from Omar Villafranca is in Austin Texas  a state where the presidential race is  closer than it has been in decades Omar  good morning good morning the polls are  open here in Texas and since everything  is bigger in the Lone Star State we are  at a mega voting site which means more  voting machines more workers and more  parking now the Republicans are expected  to win Texas but the reliably  conservative state could see a closer  than usual presidential contest now in  the last four presidential elections the  Republican candidate has won by a margin  of 10 points or more and that includes a  nearly 16 point victory for Mitt Romney  four years ago a surge of Hispanic  voters is credited with giving Clinton  to boost and almost four and a half  million Texans have already voted in the  state's 15 largest counties and that's  already 1 million more voters for early  voting than in the 2008 contest game  Omar thank you